what's going on reject nation we are
going to watch some new rock stars today
the easter eggs and trailer breakdown
for venom
let there be carnage trailer number two
and look who decided to join us today
look who actually showed up right i knew
this was coming
happy to have you you care to explain
why you weren't here
yeah i woke up a bunch of times before
my alarm went off and i didn't wake up
when it actually did
i mean everyone's been in my inbox
haranguing me so yeah
worked yeah
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and venom let there be carnage as a
new trailer that lets there be plenty of
carnage carnage
with venom do an impression of us
whenever sony releases a no way home
trailer oh [ __ ]
that is the rainy one get vaccinated and
we can revert coming this fall to come
in this september and save christmas
like keeping no way home on schedule two
sure i'll drink that kool-aid oh yeah i
haven't hearing rumors they might be
delaying it
and that a big part of it is that
because of the d variants going around i
don't know if that's a key word we can't
say or not
apparently they want everyone to get
back this is not my own political
statement
this is something that i've been hearing
a lot of sources talking about so
maybe it's true maybe it isn't but i
wouldn't be surprised if at this stage
the movie ends up getting delayed
get vaccinated i'm gonna break down this
trailer frame by frame for all the
hidden details that you might have
missed including the ways this film will
fuse or refuse to fuse to sony's other
spider-man titles we open with eddie on
his ducati
he did have a motorcycle in the first
movie but not a ducati and notice how
venom controls his hands as he drives
similar to how eddie let venom jesus
take the wheel in his previous chase
now eddie's helmet is a matching red
with a black visor and his motorcycle
jacket is black with blue stripes and
one
red stripe all of which could be part of
a color scheme to reflect his
relationship with cletus cassidy and
carnage venom in the comics is black
with a blue
outline often and carnage is of course
red with black outline
and this movie revises carnage's origin
story from eddie symbiote producing an
offspring
that fuses with his cell mate clear
scarcity to instead now be the result of
cletus biting
eddie and getting eddie's
symbiote-infused blood in his system
i have tasted blood before and that
is not it that's mine it's yours
and what's yours is mine
i actually really like that detail a big
part of what i'm loving what we're
seeing with venom let there be carnage
is how
personal everything is feeling but
protagonist and antagonist and the fact
that
cletus gets it from biting into eddie
i'm sure there's a part of it where
eddie feels really responsible now for
what's going on
so it just makes the journey that much
more personal but john what are your
thoughts on the trailer of that moment
wow i have a different thing to say
based off of what you said that's it i
just think that that's a great change
kind of i mean i'm one of the few fans
of like the organic web shooter so every
time they throw something into a movie
that's like ah that's really clever and
also really disgusting and twisted and
fitting for the character more so
probably in this case twist so i'm
for it g that would have been a great
point in yesterday's video
ah i'll record my own trailer reaction
like we did for the suicide squad no
it's the last reactions on my ties it's
okay
maybe this color design is that you got
your chocolate my peanut butter you got
your peanut butter my chocolate idea
with carnage's
early form still having that black in
his face
before he appears to go all right oh
cool
i didn't i didn't think about it similar
to the 1999 mummy who still must feast
to reach his final complaint after the
bite though
eddie's fiction today reflecting the way
cassidy has left him with some internal
ah
that's neat on this tired chew toy mark
snooki
not spelled like nicole please he spells
it but like snooky's cookies
also looks like a tire that might have
been used as a buoy on the side of a
boat that might have been named snooki
eddie warns venom that they'll be
dragged off to area 51.
and interesting of eddie to mention area
51 existing in this universe because
area 51 was the subject of a blog post
on j jonah james's daily view the
website that was released by sony now as
we still wait for a trailer for
spider-man no way home and speculate on
the ways loki and sylvie busted up the
mcu's sacred timeline into a multiverse
we gotta admit jk simmons showing up as
j jonah jameson in far from home with no
explanation
could be one way alternate universe
crossovers could have already been
happening
in the mcu and thus could signal sony
and marvel's plans to
justify how these crossovers are
happening one thing i was talking with
paul from heavy spoilers about
maybe spider-man's not getting delayed
maybe it's going to come out the release
time maybe we'll get that trailer
so late but i remember that the venom
first movie
had a scene from spider-man into the
spider-verse as its post-credits scene
so perhaps
you know like with how the morbius
trailer shows you spider-man there maybe
there'll be something in the venom
post-credits scene that directly ties
into spider-man no way home talking
about multiverse we saw daily bugle
in the first venom trailer maybe that's
part of the delay on the trail of the
release
yeah potentially i mean because think of
it i mean you know sony wanting to
bolster
their half of the universe and get
people psyched for their 900 plus
characters or whatever you know that
would be the the
surest fire way to get people to go see
venom
insert joke about john not showing up
for yesterday to keep the bit going
that's not to say venom let the green
carnage will be in the mcu no i don't
think that's gonna be the case
but with a title like spider-man no way
home i think sony might try to hint that
it could be kind of this
nexus point where on let us in
let us in we want that marvel money
first
and like this venom corner of the
universe we visit the ravencroft
institute
a prison in lab where super criminals
are experimented on in the marvel comics
an east coast version of this showed up
in the amazing spider-man 2 where
elektro was briefly kept we see this
woman with silver hair walking down the
hallway she actually later appears
outside of shriek's cell
closing the hatch that's presumably to
prevent shriek's sonic blasts from
getting out this woman also showed up
outside the chamber in the last trailer
this could be dr kafka who runs the
ravencroft institute in the comics
that would make a lot of sense who teams
up with carnage in the maximum carnage
comic that seems to be partly inspiring
this movie's plot she has the ability to
emit these powerful sonic blasts
and considering such frequencies tend to
destabilize symbiotes from their hosts
i assume she will end up being the
crucial weapon against venom or carnage
or both notice how she has one
blue eye a nod to the blue mark that is
over her eye in the comics here look
closely she is reading the daily bugle
and the headline
i think reads cletus cassidy dead maybe
cletus how did you make that out
he could have been falsely reported as
dead with guards and media either not
understanding what that carnage
transformation was
or technically this transformation
occurred after he flatlined in the
execution room
all right time to lay down a theory i
feel like shriek is going to have a
change of character ooh
and then come over to the light side or
maybe because i
herself in some way yeah i could see
that happening kind of getting a
sympathetic approach
to her from the glimpses we've been
getting i would agree with you
because i have expertise on this trailer
that you did not show off right i didn't
show up i didn't even i didn't watch it
back we did it i'm over it
this is therapy live for you and when i
do a breakdown of this movie that will
be the point i pitch a bat [ __ ] theory
that the whole movie takes place
in cletus cassidy's flickering fantasies
in the moments of his death venom breaks
eddie's nose
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it
again you are a loser and you can see
how eddie's crooked nose straightens
itself from the inside
being interviewed by media now eddie's
interviews with clevis cassidy seem to
have led to discovery of
bodies of cletus cassidy's past victims
making the police look bad and making
eddie more of a star for the daily bugle
and we see
working on that story on his laptop
daily bugle west coast edition
since of course it is based out of new
york inside the mind of serial killer
cletus cassidy we get inside the mind of
cletus cassidy the famous serial killer
of our country
in this exclusive report that delves
into his dark past investigating his
motives and madness
the masthead and logo are the same as
the design we saw in the sam rainey
spider-man movies
unlike the infowars design of the
website in the mcu now of course the
ramiverse already had a venom and the
andrew garfield mark webb had a daily
bugle and a j jonah jameson
who appeared only in angry emails in
peter parker's inbox
on the left side of the screen you can
see that eddie has an actual account
with the daily deagle server meaning
that he is working for them full time
now
among his notes are some of cletus
cassidy's drawings with a tree in a
church similar to the sketches he made
on the walls of his prison cell and on
the tree is the quote
to thee the strife was given between the
suffering
this is a line from prometheus an 1816
poem by english poet
lord byron which is a celebration of the
titan from greek mythology who stole
fire from the gods to benefit mankind it
romanticizes his defiant struggle
against the god's wrath
as he brought mortals and immortals
closer in status
similarly with a title like let there be
carnage a paraphrase from the book of
genesis
cassidy he sees himself as a god figure
seeking to immortalize himself by
stealing a power that came from the
heavens
similarly on his prison cell walls a
quote from mary shelley's frankenstein
title also known as the modern
prometheus which was written
in the same english romantic literary
era in 1818
exploring a similar subject matter of
mankind defying mortality and producing
the suffering lonely promethean figure
we gotta have a cult here we gotta have
a car
he's clearly wants it it's clearly
inspired from the comic run that
that uh did that and i like that the
trailers haven't showed us it but i just
think it would be incredibly
and awesomely sadistically
coolly did that
be the twisted most dark marvel sony
movie yet just disgusting occult
you know murder scenarios and
cannibalism
and devil worship we see a lot of
characters who
idealize themselves who think they're
some greater
being dumb pretentious serial killers
you know i think it would be cool if
he's actually starting to succeed
plus then you open yourself up to even
more symbiotes for the inevitable three
qual symbiotes
cassidy says people love serial killers
correctly observing that this latest
craze of true crime genre
and documentary series and podcasts
society really has this dark fixation
with famous sadistic psychopaths
cassidy bites eddie on his hand the same
place that peter parker
famously gets bitten to get his powers
though in this case the power transfer
goes to the biter and in the other
trailer cassidy kills a spider as he
writes these postcards to eddie which
looks like he's writing it in his blood
which might be how this relationship
grew
prior to the cross contamination cassidy
helps eddie grow in his journalistic
fame so now cassidy feels like eddie
owes him something carnage stops
cassidy's execution you can see it
leaking across his eyeballs and these
red inks
especially similar to the bluish
blackish ones in eddie's eyes in the
previous film and then
bursting out of his chest and his hands
in these red tendrils and listen closely
to this moment
yeah there's that little squeak at the
end of the roar that you can also hear
later during the prison shootout
that doesn't sound like a pained wine
released by a wounded animal but rather
a high-pitched demonic squeal made by
something whose vocal cords are involved
in
transformation like a windpipe being
turned inside out and cassidy morphs
into carnage i love how it first drains
his eyeball to form this
bulbous form of a carnage eyeball while
tugging
out the side of his mouth that he opens
to release carnage's
thick gross tongue as if this is all
tearing out from cassidy's screen
groceries the maximum carnage game but i
believe there also might be some
influences from the more recent absolute
carnage comics series which featured
carnage taking over a cult worshiping
the scenio klintart deity of
null and puppeting the unfortunate
homeless of san francisco as these
drones as he forms his church of carnage
commentary if he took over homeless
people in this movie people would say
how like
relevant this movie is conditioned
in america right now and it's using
comic books to get the message to the
people
exactly what this is for it would be
pretentiously deep
it would be exactly what everyone wanted
and i hope they knew it
and it would offend a lot of people but
the homeless people can't afford to
watch these movies
yeah yeah they're not happy to be any of
the
[Laughter]
and this was the moment that we got sent
to hell and this is when we got
cancelled
for a stupid joke we'll buy them tickets
homelessness is a serious private watch
party that's
working that's not a crime now the
previous trailer showed steven graham's
character
detective mulligan in his office with a
map of san francisco's tenderloin
district
known for its high population of
homeless people with a few incident
markings on those blocks
by the way it is believed that mulligan
could be patrick mulligan a cop who in
the comics gets infected with an
offspring of carnage to become the
character toxin
actually that would be a neat setup
you're obviously introducing this
mulligan character as a protagonist in
this film and then if there's some type
of like fall from grace if he does
become
like an evil symbiote character toxin i
imagine after doing a venom three you
might get multiple
ones to go up against tons to sell all
the seven because all the seven
symbionts
exactly so i think that would be a
really cool way to have a little bit
like a harvey dent tail to it you know
and keep on probing it like the
what human element does to you know the
symbiote relationship carnage helps
cassidy escape prison you can see as
guards are closing in one of carnage's
tendrils in the background suspend one
dude high in the air these guards shoot
at him and he
opens a hole in his chest to let the
bullet sail through and hit the guards
behind him but this also shows how
cassidy isn't like floating inside
carnage wearing him like a suit but
rather his flesh is
fully infused with the symbiote matter
that's why venom freaks out when carnage
is a red one it signals to him that
cassidy
has fully given over his blood to the
symbiote making them
one a stronger and more lethal
connection than the give and take of
eddie and venom's relationship
it's like manipulating on a molecular
level yeah it's like t-1000-ish or i've
been watching agents of shields like the
graviton the way it just yeah
it completely turns you into the
material of
the host which is it's almost like the
parasite has taken over and become the
host
yes and now the host is just a puppet
this is why i love new rock stars i
didn't pick up on that detail at all
because yeah eddie's definitely like
yeah wearing venom yeah whereas uh yeah
he's
oh that's so cute that's a difficult
pill to go up against
absolutely and maybe that lends more
credence to the idea that he could have
been
dead flatlined at the point where
carnage fully takes over carnage pins
this prison guard and gives him a
franchi
i can't really tell if he's feeding on
his organs or using the spiky tension of
his tongue to
whisk it all up and then this title card
says this fall
a bit worrisome since the release date
is supposed to be september 24th in the
u.s september 15th in the uk
making some of us a bit concerned that
maybe rising cases of the delta variant
might delay the release
no this does not mean spider-man no way
home will get pushed i just think sony
is keeping their options
open for let there be carnage carnage
faces a helicopter with his tendrils
wrapped around it looks like his
convertible there now cassidy appears
sitting next to francis in this car in
the other shot and then there's a third
shot showing francis using her sonic
blast to blow out the windshield as
someone else crazy
wrapped around this car i assume this is
all part of their escape from the
ravencroft
which you can also see as carnage's arms
explode out of the hatch of francis's
cell and another shot where it tears
down
that same ravencroft hallway that is
well photo of annie with a cat from the
first movie named mr belvedere now the
hand holding that frame has that
engagement ring
making this annie so maybe eddie
returned this photo that he had of annie
as a way of signaling that he is moved
on that he's open
where venom reacts to carnage
[Music]
where are you going there's a red one
you need to come out right now
i will let you eat everybody promise i
promise
oh yeah yes it's a bit similar to your
folks refusal to take the reigns from
bruce banner and infinity war but here
yeah venom clearly fears carnage and
cassidy's pure blood symbiosis compared
to his weaker hold on eddie
i love this detail eddie's mumford phys
ed department shirt
with his detroit lions jacket is an odd
to another famous eddie eddie murphy in
beverly hills cop2
and when eddie says i'll let you eat
everybody it's referring to multiple
enemies that they're about to face and
if you look closely on the far
end of the church on the altar beside
cassidy there is a dark figure standing
beside him that must be the final form
of shriek
we also get this pretty gnarly close-up
of carnage's head notice the texturing
on his tongue
all these black pock marks like it is
decaying and then the contouring of his
eye socket
it is jagged just like it is in the
comics like someone took their fingers
and dipped it in white paint and just
smeared it on the back of his head so
gross
victory dance outside san quentin and
then robbie what looks like mrs chen's
store
the cashier could be her son don't you
heard me says jenny's cassidy is in
eddie's neighborhood
security feed on the screen nearby shows
outside including that red convertible
driving around in and then this montage
of the fight between venom and carnage
carnage's appendages pin venom against
the wall of a church
putting him in a christ pose meaning he
might try to execute him via crucifixion
in this church it's a bit appropriate
there
at that restaurant that they dined at in
the 2018 film but if you compare
the shots of this it's blue in the other
one but that was a red illumination
symbolized carnage i have added to the
new rockstars video dude you should join
new rockstars
you didn't show up i know i screwed up
stupid and her engagement ring if you
compare that to the one eddie gave her
in the previous film now that center
stone is surrounded by
a double halo and has stones on the band
it's just a way more expensive version
of the ring that eddie got her which
might be why eddie and venom take it so
personally
you can support new rockstars by
checking out our many great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching i am never going to
wear it in this room again you have a
blue one
i made sure to get a black light
specifically evie because like freaking
johnny tell me you got one i'm sorry
wear your blue one oh okay tomorrow i'll
have it on yeah
shoot this whole reaction now oh no i
gotta go get my shirts
and i'll bring my red loki shirt too so
that yeah
well thanks for that new rockstars i
think this movie's gonna outdo the first
one by a long shot i'm really looking
forward to it yeah
guys leave your thoughts down below and
all your theories subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
subscribe to new rockstars
and hit that like button blah blah blah
i want to shout out today michael b
omnimedia who of course
was on top of this reaction yesterday
the guy's covering
so much stuff right now he is a game
changer in the reaction field and you
guys would love his reactions
so much so to the point that after he
didn't show up yesterday
i was like michael i'm looking for a
replacement
do you want to replace johnny he jumped
at the opportunity he's like
i don't know i mean can i live up to the
great john humphrey
it's very i'm like let's not get so
watch the adjectives here michael
you're definitely a man who who
understands the importance
of staying up uh late and waking up
early and never sleeping like
if anyone's got it locked down better
than me it's michael guys i want you to
welcome
the new reject to the family slowly
going to be phasing out
john here but hey after yesterday's
messages and dm's you got more followers
on social media so
it's about time you start up your own
chat they're all enthusiastic they're
all really having
comments to people who want to see more
of me michael
hey if i couldn't pick a better white
dude to replace me you were my top
choice
i was going to go with aaron alexander
from like now it's going to earn no it's
got to be another white guy don't
diversify too much i mean you're already
only half white so yeah i know
because to get the movement going for
more diversity it's got to be white
people who are speaking up for it
absolutely it's always the white guys at
the very top who have to trickle all the
changes down that's how the world works
you guys keeping it going you michael
you